boneless or bone
bone boneless boneless fat i'm a
boneless kind of guy man i'm a boneless
get that get that bone out of there if i
can't eat it get it out of my face
sometimes i just don't want to go
through the process of being like a
[ __ ] animal and tearing the [ __ ]
if i gave you two plates one of them
came from a bone chicken one came from
boneless chicken you would not be able
to tell a [ __ ] difference guaranteed
i would i would guarantee you you will
not be able to make more right now the
moisture the moisture is there it's it's
more the natural flavor of the chicken
it tastes
that is a detriment is the fact that is
a bone chicken but that's a i will
happily pay the price for a better
tasting chicken okay it's just okay and
then like when you get to the ends this
[ __ ] does not want to come off the bone
you have to like be like a feral animal
to get this thing off the [ __ ] boat
it's just time to break my
no it's not because you can eat more way
more chicken you know because boneless
chicken is your chicken breast yeah cut
up yeah it's amazing no it's not it's
not always chicken breast brown
the chicken
chicken is yeah it is always chicken
breast and the meat tastes the same on
the wings you know what you're not the
breast you know i don't think the breast
is the best part of the chicken i think
it is i think it is you know what i like
i like moisture with my meat and you can
get a more expressed the breast is you
can get a moisturizer are you kidding me
you can get emotional you can get the
moist breast right
like
a lot of the times you [ __ ] you cook
a chicken breast and it can yeah you
you're cooking it you're cooking no no
you're just [ __ ] no no my man's my man's
never did a bad job on the chicken man
it was always fresh like
like like sauce contained like i've had
enough chicken breasts and random
chippies and random places well just the
breast is too dry you can never get
under the wrong chippy no you can never
get in london i would never get a
boneless chicken they don't do boneless
chicken well enough outside that's what
i'm saying right because because you
need to cook chicken breasts right in
order for it to be when it's done right
well you don't have to pay that better
it's not even better it's not going to
be any other like korean places here and
they have boneless and and boned always
boneless always because this [ __ ] is
just better you also get more of it
because they don't they don't try and
[ __ ] stack go to nando's what'd you
get what did you get
uh like half a chicken yeah why why
don't you get the uh boneless uh the the
boneless the boneless one
when you go to nando's ah they don't do
the boneless juice yes they do i don't
even know they did that i would have got
the bone bone but now he knows so he's
gonna get the ball no no actually i joke
i don't get the half chicken i get the
butterfly burger which has no bones
because i don't want to deal with bones
that is definitely drier than the half
cheese that's why you pile on the sauce
baby oh no no if they cook it right
though they're cooking because he
doesn't eat the sauce
it's a 50-50 gamble on whether it's
gonna be juicy or not it's it's up to
the breast the breast is always [ __ ] the
breath no it's not it's totally up to
the chef man and how he cooks it for
personally you don't need to play you
don't need to pay that gamble if you
just get the half a chicken off the bone
because you know what it's always juicy
oh it's good it's good but i don't the
butterfly chicken burger is just fine as
well this is the same thing and then you
can just source it up it could be better
it could be better it's just i just
think i think the nando's chicken is
comfort food it's not the best but yeah
i don't i didn't expect five star
[ __ ] barn what's chicken fried
chicken is right it's comfort food no no
no no it's not gonna go michelin style
russell ordered fried chicken i've had
you know i've been to michelin star
restaurants and i've had times where i
just want the fried chicken more like
it's just so much better to me i love a
good fried chicken when it's done right
this man literally goes like this
in america but i feel like there's a
very american side of me
look there's there's there's a reason
why soup is made from the bones of
animals right and that's because the
bones contain flavor you're not eating
the food if i wanted to eat soup i'll
eat soup if you're not eating the
[ __ ] bone marrow god you're not
you're like i don't go to the restaurant
with you like are you gonna eat your
bones i'm gonna eat that bone marrow bro
cracks it open
you know like you're not the in the
you're not in the bone the bone doesn't
do it this bone bone does do [ __ ] it
does oh my [ __ ] god i'm sure
if they marinate [ __ ] with the bone in
yes the bone will have an effect
but when you're at fast food they
literally got that chicken in the van 20
minutes ago and it's on your plate
there's no time to have the bone plane
effect you you're just getting boned
that was god that was that was a raise
i rest my case
i'm sure it does make your difference
but not it does i'm not even gonna
notice it's not enough it's not an
argument it makes i am not even gonna
pretend to start
i'm not gonna start to pretend that i
think i know the [ __ ] difference
i don't do you have taste buds joey yeah
do you have taste buds you can tell the
difference and you have a tongue you
know what i think i'm sure man who
doesn't like sauce i don't [ __ ] trust
a goddamn thing i have taste buds and
you know what i taste [ __ ] chicken i
don't give a [ __ ] if it's from the bone
or not from the bottle oh yeah it tastes
like chicken all chicken tastes the same
joey all meat stays the same it's just
beef it tastes the same it comes from
the same animal all beef tastes the same
every cut of beef is the same all
chicken tastes the same no it doesn't
all chicken taste the same most parts of
the chicken in terms of like the skin
and the you know because the wing is
just an extension of the breast in terms
of how the meat is it's
me
i'm about to [ __ ] leave it
i didn't say that
i don't take responsibility for that
statement the ring the wing the meat
part of it tastes exactly the same
that's why they can make boneless wings
and call it wings it doesn't taste any
different the only problem is with the
bone is you get like veins and [ __ ] and
then it's like i don't want that who
wants the vein who's like what the [ __ ]
is boneless wings
the boneless swings right right go to
buffalo wild wings you get any of those
places all it is is just chicken breast
cut up
did you know that to make it look like a
wing yeah to me because like i've never
gotten boneless wings because i'm like
what the [ __ ] so you've known this week
so you've never tried it mm-hmm so
you've never tried it i've tried
boneless chicken well you said you've
never ordered it i've never tried
boneless wings but i've had like i've
boneless chicken isn't all chicken
boneless when you get it like a
restaurant
no
yeah but when you get wings boneless
swings every time no no you you gotta
it's off the bone chicken is always
tastes better off the boat it's less
healthy for you the only reason why
people promote breast is because it's
the leanest meat right that doesn't
necessarily mean it's tasty the winged
meat like the actual meat that you're
eating tastes no different
from the breast
it's the moisture content and it's it's
you it's the bone flavor that seeps into
the chicken something it just it tastes
better unless we're at a gourmet
restaurant i would i would say that's
invalid because you know these these
fast food restaurants you know and the
the place where you're eating wings from
90 percent of the time isn't going to
have the bone play any effect i'm not
going to go to buffalo while we see a
boneless chicken go what the [ __ ] is
this
okay you have a kfc bargain bucket or
your kfc [ __ ]
do you have preferences of which one
which piece you take because every piece
tastes different and if and and if
every piece of kfc chicken tastes
different depending on the part of the
chicken
the only difference is that you get a
different ratio of skin
the surface skin to like meat yeah and
with the with the wings uh with uh the
drumstick you have the optimal skin to
meet ratio yeah i can't right so you get
more skin yeah so it tastes better
whereas the big the big like flat piece
what i don't know what it's called
what's it called the big flat piece
what is it called you know i don't know
there's two pieces there's the wing and
then there's the other piece oh like
that the one that's like that it's kind
of like a big piece like this you just
get more meat yeah so you don't have as
much taste worse the the worst the water
there's less skin yeah no it tastes
worse because it's just purely in meat
right
i don't want it
on it i don't want fat i taste any no
you're confusing it because you're
having more skin which is where all the
flavor is with kfc that's why you think
it tastes better because you're getting
more bite of a skin
how are you not seeing this how are you
failing to understand this gone i i
literally don't give a [ __ ] when it
comes to kfc it's it's
talking about friendship it's all
[ __ ] chicken to me oh my [ __ ] bone
or no bone the best all chicken like i
love boneless wings i love fried chicken
burgers yeah i love uh the like chicken
select so where the chicken tendy's
chicken tendies are [ __ ] amazing
chicken tenders are better than nugs
down and and wings with bones in them
snugs are like the the part of the
chicken that nobody else eats right i
think they've repackaged it
but like you know why it's the worst
tasting part of the chicken boneless
boneless is better than bones are you
are so wrong on something like you know
what i'm not i'm not man i didn't think
freedom of speech was a mistake until i
hurt until i just heard you speaking bro
you're a clown man like why are you
making it more difficult to eat this and
you're making more mess
you're the reason flat earth has existed
no i'm not like this is this is like
is it isn't boneless just like that
no no no no no no no no
shut up
you're not in this conversation boneless
nuggets nuggets are like chicken extract
it's hardly a chicken it's it's paste
you know yeah it's like uh it's like
polystyrene with chicken tasting
you know and chicken tendees are good
chicken tenders chicken tenders are
awesome chickens i think we're all
agreement chicken tenders are good yeah
we're on agreement yeah i mean off the
bone chicken is always the best um
that's that that is yeah when it's taken
off the boat yeah we're taking off the
boat off the bone and then fried and
then presented kind of like
yeah
no no no no no no no no no
no no
[Music]
no because because you're taking the the
most tastiest
chicken off the bone is literally
boneless chicken with one extra step
[ __ ] the breast is the worst tasting
part of the chicken
chicken
have you tasted chicken [ __ ] it's the
most healthiest you're going to be huh
have you had chicken feet okay well
that's okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah backtrack okay okay
it's the most it's the worst tasting
part of the chicken that's like actually
you know
it's got me like meat white meat yeah
it's got meat on it right technically
it's it's the most healthiest for you
you know it's it's you know if you want
to eat a healthy meal you should eat the
leanest part of the chicken but that
doesn't necessarily mean it tastes the
best and the fact that you think that
all chicken tastes the same no matter
what part of the chicken is from you are
so wrong the meat part of it like the
breast the wing it all comes to know how
it's prepared it doesn't you know it's
entirely to do with that and how much
water has been injected into it like
if
you prepare each part of the chicken the
same which is exactly what fried chicken
is then the worst placing uh then but it
tastes the same then it doesn't taste
toasty
again i guarantee i can take two
different fried chicken from two
different parts put it in front of you
blindfold you would not be able to hold
it i would because [ __ ] brass
especially in fried chicken it's not
moist at all it's dry a lot of the time
i think you're just you know you're
confusing the feral instinct of tearing
it off as a as a supplement for flavor i
think i think that's what's going on
here because there's no way you know
when you rip the skin off and you would
eat it it tastes the same why don't they
just sell breasts then why why because
chicken tastes the same they do it's
called boneless wings yeah
no i mean i mean why why why market
wings in that case because people are
like you why would you think they know
the difference
thighs because what do you mean thighs
because thighs are like uh what are they
i mean like more cartilage they're
cheaper right like they're normally just
like they have more like [ __ ] in them
more muscle and stuff what the cartilage
of chicken it's like muscle i'm not
talking about color i'm talking about
thighs you said thighs and cartilage i
just said oh yeah thighs have more like
cartilage in them though like unlike th
and like [ __ ] muscles and spikes it's
just me it's it's a different part of
the meat that tastes a bit different to
the breast no the thighs have more
muscle in them it's a thigh
the breast has more muscle in it it's we
literally talked about this the breast
is the lean part of the chicken that's
the part with the most muscle no no i'm
just gonna hang back
you know when you bite into a meat right
when you've bought thigh there's just
loads of like fibers and [ __ ] that you
gotta like
oh [ __ ] you know what i mean
no
what i really don't when you go to the
supermarket and you cut up chicken thigh
you can bed a chicken breast the breast
is like nothing in it you're a female
cook it's your pure meat right the thigh
it's just like it's got like like
[ __ ] strands of muscle in it and [ __ ]
and it's way tougher it's it's it's
because it's a thigh it's got [ __ ]
muscle
i don't think i don't think we've ever
been this silent have you ever cooked a
chicken thigh and a chicken breast you
know i'm like i can't argue that you
know why like if you argue with an idiot
they'll just take you down to their
level and beat you with experience man
how can i argue
with you you're just like wrong on so
many [ __ ] levels
like a thigh doesn't have the most
amount of muscle because it's it's not
the lean meat right it's the breast the
breast is pure muscle it's pure muscle
what do you think or like all the meat
is muscle right but the breast the
reason the breast has the most muscle is
because it doesn't come with the bone
you have just you have a pure slab of
pure chicken muscle
what are you saying oh my god
the breast isn't just one big muscle
what what do you think meat is
what do you think meat is it's a layer
of different things there's like fatty
layers and stuff as well it's a whole
combination thing such an all just pure
muscle
yes it is no it is no no because it's
like fibers and stuff that connects all
the muscle
that's a muscle
i gotta google this i gotta consult
google
i'm like losing my mindset
i'm actually losing my mind
a breast can dick like like it consists
of like fat
yeah it's this this is just turned into
iris which is a part of the which is a
muscle
yeah
are you are you all entertained
i am i'm not i'm loving i'm just sitting
back just watching you guys lose it over
literal pieces of chicken i'm losing
brain cells man like that's like
i don't know how many brain cells has
just died in this case
i can't believe you're getting heated
over poultry
it's just hilarious i i misunderstood
what i was saying i've googled it
i i misunderstood tendons and like
muscles and i confused the two
it's all right man it's it's all right
to admit when you're wrong it's all good
it's all good i'm wrong you know what
you're the bigger man you're the bigger
man don't worry man i'll admit when i'm
wrong i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
thank you you know this episode started
really you know this episode started
really calmly talking about candles
incense you know de-stressing and and
it does taste worse it ends up being one
of the most stress inducing
why couldn't we have started on this it
ended on the massage that died it tastes
worse i'm saying because the muscle is
used more often than the breast it not
only became the most stress inducing
argument but also at the same time i
think it became
i'm googling it again i think it became
one of the most stupid arguments we've
ever had on trash taste the reason the
breast meat is the most lean is because
that's the muscle that's the most used
no it's the least used
audio only listeners you might want to
watch tune into the youtube version of
this to see
two men melting down over poultry i'm
just like only on trash taste
you know what i didn't think we could
get more heated than the pizza crust
argument yeah
[Laughter]
is considered a darker meat because it's
used way more when it's because they're
walking all the [ __ ] time they're not
[ __ ] using their breasts all the time
so what's lean meat then lean meat i
think it's when it's used less
is it i think it's not good it's got
less fat content compared to other parts
of the meat
i thought that was because it was used
the most so here's what google says
apparently uh i googled why is thigh
dark meat and it says uh the more
myoglobin the darker the meat and the
richer the nutrients my globe provides
muscle with oxygen required for exercise
and movement since chickens are flatless
birds they use their legs and thighs to
get around making those thoughts darker
than the breasts or wings because you're
not you're using how would you how how
would you think that the breast is used
more than the thigh how does that make
any sense to use your breasts more than
your thigh gone think
i was wrong on the muscle part yes but
how could you think that the breast is
used more than that i i
i really breathe
but you're still wrong you're still
[ __ ] wrong
we're we're both [ __ ] idiots and
welcome to trash taste welcome to trash
talk welcome to the trash chest two
idiots arguing over chicken
i i feel like i feel like 30 minutes
wasn't enough
i just want to know how you thought the
chicken walked in your mind
[Music]
i just want to know how you thought
the breasts had less muscle we all know
actually i just
[Laughter]
oh my
i just thought lean meat just had uh
more muscle use that's what i thought i
thought when i hear the word lean meat
it means it's got less fatty content so
i just see someone's lean right they
have some muscles but not that much
right you kind of have like no it's not
worked out me right it's kind of like
not fat meat but not
very skinny or like that like i think
right am i crazy here it's just me
you say someone's lean when they look
like
yeah there's no fat content yeah right
right you got lean yeah so so i assumed
that because it was lean meats then it
would have less fat content therefore it
was the one that was used the most right
that's what that's because
yeah i guess by that logic it'd be like
if i didn't do anything and didn't and
didn't have any fat i would be muscular
that's right but i'm not using my
muscles because
i'm still like confused because the more
you use a muscle the more the more like
muscular it becomes the more nutrients
it demands so how does the breast have
the most meat and muscle in it then so
so when you're working out right the
muscle fibers become a lot more like
intense and i believe they go through
like they're in the the meat a lot more
right i think if i'm correct in saying
that yeah the the that's cause that's
what makes like when you when you go to
space right your muscles get [ __ ] the
muscle fibers are so weak because they
haven't been used so when they i believe
when they're being used they're a lot
more intense and that's why when you
have the thigh it's it bites back a lot
more it's tougher to eat because the the
muscle fibers are so much stronger
that's what i how i interpreted it right
right
again i i misunderstood and that's why
lean meat because the breast isn't you
know you're really using the breast much
so there's not much muscle fiber to
plant there yeah yeah
i don't even know where to take this
conversation anymore i'm just like
i'm just like i i don't think this
episode can peak anymore then yeah i
feel like i feel like i'm just gonna go
downhill yeah we're just gonna go
downhill from here so you know what
let's just [ __ ] like solve the
patrons this might be a shorter episode
than usual but uh i i i don't i feel
like any other topic we can take from
this is gonna it's gonna be good let's
just let's just end while we're high
yeah let's just say while we're at the
high just joey had a fun spectrum
i was literally that you know that meme
of like the two guys
yeah i was i was just like sunday
afternoon over here watching yeah just
like i just like how we had such a civil
podcast
having such a simple podcast and i
literally remember the moment when it
was just like i didn't say it on purpose
but i just said i
disagree
and then
i didn't do that on purpose i know
that's the mean by it yeah i seriously
didn't do that conversation is like
modern day times you know when things
get too peaceful war is bound exactly
exactly we went from aromatherapy to two
men was veins popping out on their
forehead over here oh you think candles
are good
well that's how world war one started